everyone has had something to say about
fat Thor and Avengers endgame and now
Robert Downey jr. is added his two cents
chatting with variety as part of the
outlets cover story all about Thor
himself Chris Hemsworth Downey jr. spoke
out about the god of thunder striking
new physique Thor is he asleep the five
years after the Avengers post infinity
war face off with fan OHS which ended
with Thor two capitate in the tyrants
weren't kind to the god of thunder
the mightiest Guardians sank into a pit
of grief isolating himself to a small
Shack in newest guard and spending his
days eating drinking and yelling at kids
for playing for tonight he emerged after
the time jump sporting a shaggy beard
unkempt hair that grew to his shoulders
and a protruding belly courtesy of
barrels of beer and newfound love for
cheese where's Chevy Thor divided fans
the where does he I'm an actor sit on
the spectrum Downey jr. revealed to
Variety that he adores what Hemsworth
did with the character and praised his
all-or-nothing performance boy did he go
bonkers he went out to the bleeding edge
I have a rule which is if you think
you're at 70% then start pulling back
because it's probably at a hundred and
five percent he went out into some
pretty risky atmosphere of nuttiness
together
Hemsworth relished the experience of
pushing himself to his limits and
continuing to take risks with Thor
in fact Hemsworth was so excited about
being able to play Thor in a different
way and enjoyed chubbier Thor so much
that he pushed to keep the heroes
plumper shaped throughout the entirety
of endgame lobbying to not have Thor
undergo to plan the mid movie
transformation where he gets fit again
he told variety
I like that anything goes you're not
logged in to expectations
I enjoyed that version of Thor it was so
different than any other way I played
the character and then it took on a life
of its own
give me that
hemsworth even found some joy in the not
so fun parts of portraying fat for
namely the heavy silicone prosthetics
and extra weights he had to wear saying
physically it was a good three hours of
the hair and makeup then the prosthetic
suit particularly for the shirt off
scene that was a big silicon that
weighed about 90 pounds it was certainly
exhausting
I had weights on my hands and ankles
just to have my arms and legs swing
definitely when I shuffled along through
the set people just kept coming up and
killing me like a big bear or rubbing my
belly like I was pregnant or trying to
sit on my lap like I was Santa Claus you
get a lot of affection
I felt like an old man an old grandpa
with a bunch of kids around Downey jr.
wasn't the only end game guy who had
kind words to say about chubby Thor the
film's co-director Anthony Russo shared
with variety that Thor's arcane endgame
was among his favorite narratives the
entire film like Downey jr. Russo also
applauded Hemsworth commitment to his
character parts of Christmas magic as a
comedic actor is a sad occasion to the
depth of the character on a very earnest
level it's so devious and subversive
when comedy is coming from a place of
complete commitment and emotional
complexity while those over in the
Marvel camp but clearly couldn't get
enough of fat for others were less keen
on the characters new look his
transformation from fit to fat largely
due to the trauma of the decimation and
the subsequent grief Thor struggled to
work through didn't sit well with some
viewers many of whom felt that Avengers
and the game was poking fun at his
troubles rather than celebrating him in
the way they felt the film was doing
with other heroes at the end of the day
though it looks like fat Thor is here to
stay as Hemsworth has no desire to exit
the Marvel Cinematic Universe any time
soon it's tough to do more to be honest
and I don't know what the plan is I feel
like we've opened up such a different
character I feel more energized for the
possibility of where it could go check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more loop of videos about the
MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you
[Music]